crown stars five four four nine six I am
the first of six players so if you'd
like to enter we will be playing against
each other this is a round-robin 960
rated experience level 30 first ones to
get in there quickly who is going to
track it down three players we are
waiting for two players one player we
have everybody this is the group of six
three minutes of Fisher random chess so
let's see how this one works out let's
see
starting up right now crown starts five
four four nine six round robin 960 rated
six players have entered average rating
2041 let's see what we have with this
arrangement okay unprotected this pawn
is unprotected this pawn is unprotected
I like this as a start helps out with my
queen I could Castle on move one so to
Kim my opponent King side Castle I don't
think there's going to be a better
square than Knight g3 I'm looking to
establish just some control in the
center
d4 might want to go with b4 to get this
rook working first so b4 and then Knight
here let me get my knight working first
and I think I'll be considering b4 very
soon let's go for right now I want to do
something that's very Benko gambit like
in that of a3 that seems pretty
interesting okay we're not having that
though alright help out my dark scrub
Bishop I don't want to go in this
direction
a4 okay I don't know if this is the good
idea to open up the position
like this hmm because of what I'm gonna
be netting upon huh let's see let's go
with this first take the rook and I
think this pawn wall didn't follow the
Queen Tay if Queen takes he end up
losing a rook
so pawn takes I take this rook and I
could take the pawn and then the Queen
gets down here and is hitting everything
the bishop at night so maybe instead as
an adjustment I could emphasize some
more control get more development in and
hit this pawn for now a second time hit
twice defended one our defendant zero so
he's likely to fall what is this Knight
up to nothing over here I have control
on that side and let me get castled I'm
really considering this
III move there's no need to capture this
pawn just yet he's still not going
anywhere so maybe I want to come out in
this direction with my bishop this was a
dual-purpose move open this diagonal and
also watch over this square and playing
right here right now it's not a good
idea no I like this diagonal better one
reason to maybe not go forward with
Bishop f3 while it hits the knight then
maybe runs into later Knight h4 stuff
and that could be quite annoying we come
in this direction pointing at the King
in the night my queen is restricted to
the defense of this Knight play here I
also consider get my Bishop working but
maybe I just want to get out of harm's
way in fact let me do this and now I'm
threatening in some lines Bishop before
and the rook is stuck right now in
particular
so I think this move was being played so
that this poet could run well actually
it still it can't run adjacent diagonals
this pin we have less than one minute
for black so he's maybe my opponent was
doing this move thinking that they can
move the pond but I was even forgetting
that so let me I think I want to chase
the Queen before I take the rook I want
to chase the Queen to a square where
maybe I could then pivot on this square
with the tempo for example Queen playing
here so now I take and then I can jump
in here and be on the bishop welcome to
more trades of course since I'm the side
that's not material there anything
better than should just take the bishop
actually that Bishop isn't going
anywhere let me get my knight involved
he's stuck the queen is defending
defensive position the last thing I want
to do is get my queen working this
structure I want to keep as is okay they
resign III and f2 I just want to keep
that to rule out the bishop stuff and
okay well they they ended up giving up
their back to tournament okay these
games are not gonna start right away
there still is one more going on so
let's dive in and see what's going on
here and it seems like well this King
needs to get over here to defend this
pawn the bishop is there in time but now
I think it's going to be a draw yes just
pawn push Bishop takes pawn King takes
pawn
any mating material however what's with
that move oh they missed just pawn push
and now White's gonna win or are they
have to look for me where is the main
King here Queen here's me point four
seconds oh oh
black ended up winning there was a
meetin one oh that's a tough one
oh those hurt those are painful I could
I know firsthand how that is okay we got
action that round
done round two oh man okay this guy is
unprotected and this guy is not
protected where's this night going let
me do this cuz now opening up this
diagonal can maybe take this guy take
that pun I have some control over the
center and let me get another pounding
up both lanes both diagonals from our
bishops my knight probably is not going
to have a better spot than b6 if this
pawn moves that could actually be pretty
good attacking my Center and this pond
and if this pawn Falls my rook will fall
and that's what's being threatened so
let's get my knight out right away just
how they defended with their night on g3
I have to be careful these two squares
definitely good jumping points for the
night so I'll really want to consider e6
and okay well we could take and then no
I don't want to help my opponent bring
their Queen out would they really do
that I could Castle that's another thing
we could have both castle down our first
move these squares are weak these light
squares this Bishop is kind of devoted
on this side of the board only
let's get my night out pawn takes rook
takes the Queen can play here and attack
my rook but I have a counter attacking
rook c4 if there's ever this capture
that's just going to benefit me because
I recapture my pawns are my one pawn is
watching over these two squares that I
consider very sensitive so what more
what's this bishops future going to be
where will this night end up residing
maybe Knight here putting pressure on
this and now okay if I take this pawn
Bishop takes pawn or night if I take
this pawn rook here I might want to
still just do that I'm gonna I'm going
to go forward with that I'm gonna take
that guy Bishop takes pawn rook here if
look to this square I might want to
consider taking this Knight it could be
a bit dangerous actually
let's see who's better developed do I go
King side castle if I went to queenside
castle I need to move my Queen and
Bishop only there has to be no pieces in
between my king and my ruck and I drop
my King on top and that's it so I don't
really have much choice and I think I
want to run away with my knight before I
end up in a pin and while this structure
might end up looking ugly having double
isolated pawns again it it cancels out
this guy on g3 and now this knight is
putting pressure on this pawn okay so
maybe now is the time to just take I
don't know that that could have been
maintained in a great way and now oh I
was just gonna do this but then Bishop
takes Knight followed up with the fork
that would be a problem so I would okay
maybe I it's time to move the knight
where do you want to go yeah let's get
him out of harm's way let's go here in
the center I was for a second
considering this square maybe Bishop
here hitting the rook but it just gets
hit with this this Knight is a bit loose
with that last move what is my queen
doing there's my light square bishop
doing let me do
take out that f5 square this diagonal
has been opened but I could control it
with my dark square Bishop I think this
is a good spot Queen c7 get my light
square Bishop out this is a nice square
and maybe this one too let's do this
get my bishop here and then queenside
castle and I think things are looking
pretty good
what type of pond move might my opponent
be going forward with there down on time
as well less than 40 Bishop d7 queenside
castle get my rook on h2 okay castle and
get my King off of this file very soon
this is going to be a weak point I want
my rook on c8 the ship here was to stop
Knight moves here but let's do this
watch over this square oh they're doing
that okay I'm on this pawn pawn push I
could do tonight here I have to be
careful we are on opposite sides and I
have pressure with this last night move
amount pressure here I really want to
take on this square I think that is
actually quite all right I play back
here I have enough defense this Knight
isn't doing much
it's a passed pawn and this is a good
coordination now I think I just keep
rolling with this pun and I'm very
tempted to just take this pot I'm gonna
go for it no no it's not necessary
get my rook working now get this pawn
going take this keep going with my pawn
get my knight working next there in a
pin if I take here there's eventually
some check that would happen against my
King so let me just get my night working
bishop here was also worth considering
man that clean and rook and there's not
really going to be a good solution at
all just really anything at that point
they don't have any time back to
tournament okay
one more game where we add in the
standings quick look at the standings
okay it just didn't register that there
was a win with that one just yet so
we'll see unless this is the other game
that's going on five seconds for white
in 12 seconds for black repetition King
sneaks over oh oh I thought this panel
is one little way from cleaning just oh
I'm looking in the wrong direction I'm
thinking why isn't why isn't d2 being
played
okay black ended up winning that one
okay where are we at in the standings if
they registered there we are with the
standings okay - - alrighty okay I have
team white when I see these bishops off
to the corners I think that they just
don't have to move in order to develop I
could castle on my first move I have to
be cautious about this Bishop here let
me do this move for starters mm let me
go with this one bring my night out and
then do this pawn push so I'm opening up
one diagonal I'd like to get two pawns
here and then both Knights right behind
them and then the bishops are backing
them up so b3 but if this pawn moves
first off I'll play Knight c3 and then
b3 and then I have some discovered
tricks available I did this oh man I
want to do d4 as a bad mouse live it
could be worse though could be worse
I just tried to develop my bishop like a
knight okay you can't do that and now
where am I going with this guy see that
was silly
I could Castle but maybe it's time to
start working on what let me get right
no that's bad - what's this Bishop going
to do now let's try this
I'm push I think it's important to do
this move otherwise this Bishop ends up
getting crushed I want to be able to
meet pawn push with just takes this pawn
up now
I think h4 they're doing that to free
their queen and that's why I went with
that move as well maybe Knight here
clean up I think that is a good choice
and go with this
what's this not going to do anything
dangerous I should probably get castled
soon I guess I could still Castle
queenside I could castle on either
direction right now my afraid of a
knight move here I don't think I should
be so now what how do I make more
progress Knight f3 has my attention
Knight f3 to g5
yeah Knight f3 to g5 could be quite
annoying and it's something with like a
pawn push okay hang on mate so has
pressure on this my opponent is doing uh
getting to that g5 square as well um I
don't want to take I just help the rook
out right here get it to f4 this just
gives this nice home um I'm gonna go
with this it's a bit scary it's
definitely a bit scary maybe Knight here
Knight f3
alright there's stuff with like captures
Bishop takes Knight and then Knight here
or Bishop check but I think I should be
okay
my bishops again like I was saying the
beginning of the game they really don't
need to develop I feel like my queen is
ready to get trapped I think I need to
support this pun so let me do this it
might be okay with the bishop takes and
then taking with the pawn that way this
Knight has to get out of there
at the very least he's got to run away
oh boy what else okay we're about even
on time my queen is doesn't have very
much movement pawn push maybe that's a
way to open it up okay oh my goodness I
gotta take like that my queen is so dead
take like that this probably could be
taken oh my goodness I just got a move I
just got a move oh now this pawn is hit
OK after bring my bishop out to defend
oh ok centralize my knight let my bishop
okay maybe I could get this guy back I
could that Knight has to go cannot deal
with that Knight
okay so I have a pawn back I have a
tricky Knight that is here he's on the
scene can I make use of him in any way
Knight takes pawn with the fork
threatening the Queen to watch out g2
Queen Bishop battery they only have 23
seconds and I can always drop back maybe
I could pile up getting I want to get
out of that pin I think yes let's get
out of that pin as soon as possible
Queen takes Queen
Oh night here is actually working Brooke
here it's a way out of it
very nice I got a defend against that
that was very nice and now my night is
very close to being stuck I think
immediately playing here would have been
better to keep the Queen's alright yeah
the Queen's the rooks on the board put
pressure on their night I want to keep
these guys around and they don't have
much time I want to create some pawn
target now they've helped repair my pawn
structure and I have a very active rook
right now this is the new 7th rank where
there are all these pawns and now
there's just no time very very good game
yeah I'm attack back to tournament land
wow that was a very very good game you
were in a much much better position data
you fractured my kingside structure so I
believe round 3 were raided waiting for
around 4 this is where we're at in the
standings deed deagle honest is uh ok
here we go here we go
we both have three I believe what's
unprotected okay let's do this or this
or let's go with this helping out my
queen and Bishop and then I could play
Knight f3 if I'm to Castle kingside I
have to clear out both knights and both
the Knights and Bishop and Queen okay
okay well I get we could develop our
Knights classically so he's got to come
out in this a a two direction and what
else
right here right now let's try that
Knight takes pawn takes Knight here okay
you take that which Knight do I take if
Knight takes that's not good cuz I take
and then there's a pin you got to just
do this and then there's some some
issues structurally oh who I'm singing
about getting my queen here with check I
could do this but I just closed the door
my dark square bishop so I think I want
to play here first and then pawn push
and then I think a four a five I think a
four we met with a5 Bishop here might be
considered but maybe I could have this
as a response so Queen f2 and then a
very long King side Castle okay Bishop
here is now not good because it
interferes with the rooks defense of
this a pond I believe this is being
threatened but maybe I do this to secure
my pawns position that's probably gonna
be the follow-up however I still think
it's a good idea though I'm gonna go
with this pawn push I could play a three
if we exchange a pawns I'm still here to
defend my rook and now with the rooks
off Queen coming here is going to be
quite dangerous so I think I could force
black to go uncle I'm ready to bring my
queen out and this Bishop is really
really stuck how does he get working
okay voluntarily going there and I think
I just bring my queen out in that
direction she's just seemed it seems
like the correct thing to do also maybe
Bishop a2 is available Queen here might
be played and then queen a8 though has a
response and the bishop is still stuck
even if the bishop moves there is no
like rook through have a queen this
bishop can only come out on one way and
now oh I could grab this pond I could
have done that on the last move I could
have traded Queens and then taken the
pond ah that would have been so simple I
would have been up a full rook in a pond
ah
I missed that could I still just take it
I'm gonna take it and run away
take the pot and run away okay I don't
know that I really want a castle
let's do this what's the time situation
less than a minute
oh that would have been so simple being
up that up that what up that peace Queen
here I think the rook is close to
trapped oh it's just a free Queen oh I
was gonna go there no matter what we're
not mad no matter what but certainly if
there's a queen there ah that was missed
okay back to turn real and that was
around four there is one more game
remaining let's see if there's another
one going on okay there's still this one
left still quite a bit of time a minute
10 verses 42 minute 10 verses 42 how do
you assess this position okay well black
is up a minor piece and the extra pawns
that white has these two in particularly
where there's a three to one majority
they're not really any threat to go
further however this could be quite
annoying but not right to f7 yep that
was uh that's a tough one there that
tricky night he retreated and defended
f7 I missed that I was just thinking oh
look here it's a good idea put pressure
or try and b7 but not the case is there
potential for time burning anytime
burning pawn points pawn push pawn push
self stalemate 13 seconds there's crazy
King crazy King and now the king is
getting walked all the way to a queen f1
mate g2 but we have resignation so there
is just one more game that is the end of
round 4 we're waiting for around five
this is where we at with the leaders for
three and here we go last game of this
tournament this is unprotected I can't
move my palm just yet what else is
unprotected this is a pretty much the
same Queen side okay I think we're going
to end up
in a very similar position to regular
chess not too long from now so let me
get my knight out first and then I could
get castled and I'm already feeling ket
out so this is a very accelerated
version of what this is a very
accelerated version of what okay you get
this pawn working a very accelerated
version of just regular chassis and I
think I might want to go two steps let's
go two steps now this pawn can't move
just yet
let's get my knight working there on
their classical squares
let's do similar I'll castle as well g6
they should Bishop's being fee and
Quetta but let me make sure these two
pawns don't get side by side that could
be quite strong and I'll shut down the
bishop this pawn has to be broken up
that's why we have it being challenged
right away so let me take and I do next
I'm going to play here I was gonna do
Bishop d7 but I think something like f5
could have been quite strong and more
Bishop has to do something that is not a
better square than this one maybe double
up on the D file to be cautious this
nights going to pivot here soon if he
moves I think I play my knight into this
square but now I think I'd do this right
away I'm on this pond when the Queen was
in the corner I couldn't do this not at
least without dropping upon so this
Bishop is can't he can't move just yet
and now I think I stand better because
of this pond having great depth but
maybe I should rule out f5 is this move
best I think it is
stop this advance to follow up with the
knight here or actually here and then
into this square so yeah this is a very
very strong spot for my knight and I
could look to also target this pawn this
rook could be doing something else I'm
looking to for ways to improve my
position I mean okay so this this Bishop
is strictly defensive but no let's come
over here I've put pressure on this pawn
my queen I think could probably do
something more you know what I'm just
gonna give up the pawn no I'm not really
giving up a pawn I get this one in
return I'm just saying that even if I'm
down upon there's so many dark square
weaknesses I'm just gonna take that out
and now this pawn is going to be secured
let me do this first and then there's
always this pin which is what we have
right now a minute six this pod could
move and is hitting my queen so let's
get out of that and now Queen takes pawn
I'm not considering taking this rook
until they work out of the pin so I have
Queen check
and I believe that that will net a full
ruck because this guy is pinned so check
and then even he'll if a rut block
another check less than a minute - one
minute 12 and we have resignation I
right
good game - there - a comma Atari back
to turn wetland alright let me close out
let me see what other games are going on
to finish this one up there's two other
ones let's try this one
okay 30 seconds for white the tricky
Knights are around up a minor piece this
Bishop is pinned it's now unpin that's
being hit again it doesn't have a great
spot to go to Mahan one is a threat rook
here ends up winning that piece but
there is more attention just being given
to time sneaking the King up here this
is me King here it's me oh there was a
mate right there rook f5 was me oh ah so
close wasn't it that was so close
fourteen seconds
Tom push would have been good too on the
rook pawn push Knight check
ten seconds
get going pine there he goes a pod is
dead nine seconds is it going to be
enough
eight seconds a check clean position
King position watch out for the
stalemates King on f6 main five point
one seconds
light winds close out of that
is there another game going on this is
the last game of the tournament four
seconds for white 22 for black plenty of
time and we have black winning that one
alright where's plays confetti land
let's close out of that okay
good games off to those of you that
played in the crown stars five four four
nine six five four three two one zero in
the head of order cool
good good tournament my favorite game
was against gamma tech that was a really
really strong game very very nice